now in this video we will study the
trigeminal nerve or the cranial nerve v
this is the largest cranial nerve coming
to the introduction the trigeminal nerve
it arises from four nuclei three of
these nuclei are the sensory nuclei and
one is the motor nucleus now these four
nuclei combine and give rise to three
branches the v1 or the ophthalmic branch
the v2 or the maxillary branch and the
v3 are the mandibular branch of the
ophthalmic and the maxillary are purely
sensory and the mandibular branch is
mixed having both sensory and motor
component in the next section of this
video we will study how the trigeminal
nerve originates and next part of the
video we will study the course and the
distribution of these branches
now coming to the origin of the
trigeminal nerve I have drawn two views
here first is the lateral view and
second is the transverse section of the
pons the first coming to the lateral
view the this is the midbrain this is
the pons this is the medulla and this is
this spinal cord the upper part of the
spinal cord
now the trigeminal nerve arises I have
just mentioned before from four nuclei
the three of them are sensory and one as
the motor nucleus now the first nucleus
we are going to talk about is the
missing cephalic nucleus this is
situated in the midbrain and thus known
as a missing cephalic and the second
nucleus second sensory nucleus is the
principal sensory nucleus which is
situated in the bonds and the third is
this final nucleus which is a very long
nucleus and situated in the lower part
of the medulla and the upper spinal cord
now the one motor nucleus which is
situated in the pons and this is located
here now these three nuclei the missing
cephalic the primary sensory nucleus and
the spinal nucleus are the effin nuclei
this is the trigeminal ganglion
so these receive the afferent nerve
fibers from the trigeminal ganglion
these red fibers these green fibers and
the blue fiber which I have depicted
these are the F and nuclear different
fibers and this is the motor nucleus and
this is an efferent nucleus and this
sends these orange fibers which have
shown to the trigeminal ganglion which
run through the third division of the
trigeminal nerve
mandibular nerve and supply the muscles
of the first prinkle arch now this is
the transverse section of the pons
showing the origin of the trigeminal
nerve now this these three are the
nuclei of the trigeminal now at the
level of the pons now this is the
principal sensory nucleus this is the
missing cephalic nucleus in the middle
and this orange is the motor nucleus
spinal nucleus I have not shown in this
section because it is situated in this
section of the lower medulla and the
upper part of the spinal cord now let's
look at the course of the trigeminal
nerve its division into its main three
branches and then the subsequent
distribution on the face as I have
mentioned earlier the pons is the site
of the origin of the trigeminal nerve
this is the main trunk and this is the
trigeminal Canyon now the trigeminal
ganglion is situated in the middle
cranial fossa now in the temporal bone
there is a depression known as the
trigeminal cave which is the site for
the location of trigeminal ganglion from
this trigeminal ganglion the three main
branches the ophthalmic the maxillary
and the mandibular branch of the
trigeminal nerve arrives first let's
come to the first division that is the
ophthalmic division of the trigeminal
nerve now the ophthalmic division arises
in the middle cranial fossa from the
trigeminal ganglion it runs forward and
through the superior orbital fissure it
exits the cranium and divides into three
main branches now before exiting through
the superior orbital fissure the
ophthalmic branch of the trigeminal
now runs through the lateral wall of the
cavernous sinus three main branches
after exiting the superior orbital
fissure are the frontal branch the
necessary branch and the lacrimal branch
now coming to the area of distribution
of the autonomic branch of the
trigeminal nerve the area of
distribution is shown in this green part
and the frontal branch of the ophthalmic
division supplies the forehead the area
of the scalp and also it supplies the
frontal and the ethmoid sinuses the
nasal ciliary branch it supplies the
upper eyelid the cornea and the dorsum
of the nose
whereas the lacrimal branch which
receives the fibers from the Teleco
palatine ganglion it supplies the
lacrimal gland the second division of
the trigeminal nerve which arises from
the trigeminal ganglion is the maxillary
division now this branch also runs
forward and exits the cranium through
the foramen rotundum
now after exiting through the foramen
rotundum the maxillary brush divides
into fourteen branches and supplies the
middle part of the face now this branch
also runs through the latter part of the
cavernous sinus area of distribution of
the maxillary branches this area which
is shown in the pink and after its exit
through the foramen rotundum
the maxillary division divides into 14
branches which supply the lower eyelid
the conjunctiva the skin of the cheek
the maxillary sinus the nasal cavity
upper lip the molar incisors and the
canine upper canines and the superior
part of the palate a third division of
the trigeminal now the v3 is the
mandibular branch now this is the only
of the three branches which have
both motor and the sensory component
mandibular branch area is shown in this
yellow area after its exit to the
foramen ovale the mandibular branch
divides into four terminal branches the
buccal branch inferior alveolar or acute
temporal and the lingual branch and the
area of distribution includes the mucous
membrane of the oral cavity the external
ear lower lip the skin of the chin and
anterior 2/3 of the tongue the
mandibular branch also has the motor
component so it supplies the muscles of
the first branchial arch which includes
the muscle of the mastication including
the temporalis muscle the lateral and
the medial pterygoid the masseter muscle
it also supplies the tensor tympani in
the air and the tensor veli palatini of
the palate so this was an overview
regarding the trigeminal nerve I hope
you find this video informative please
support our efforts to make more videos
by subscribing to this channel and also
please leave a thumbs up for this video
thank you